Former President
Donald Trump
returned to the campaign trail
in the next few hours
when he hold a rally in Pennsylvania.
And this hour, his former vice president,
Mike Pence, is holding a campaign
event in Iowa.
CNN's Kyung
Lah is at that event
in the town of Nevada.
So, Kyung,
almost all of the GOP candidates
were in Iowa last night for dinner
We didn't hear much of a change in tone
from a lot in the field last night.
So what?
What are you looking for today?
Well, we're expecting
to see the former vice
president show up just shortly
in the next couple of minutes
or so, Fredricka.
And and really
what we're going to be looking for
is to hear
if he indeed does take a different tone
when it comes to his former
running mate, Donald Trump.
But as far as what
Pence is going to be doing here today,
I just want to walk you around.
We're actually in a fire station.
And the people you see seated over here,
these are first responders
of the Nevada Fire Department.
This is an all volunteer
fire department with the exception
of the paid police chief.
And on the docket today,
they're going to be talking about
public safety issues, issues
dealing with the local community.
And that's what they're going to be
focusing their question that's on.
And it's something
that the former vice president
would like to talk about.
He wants to talk about these issues
that affect Iowa
caucus members
and try to turn away from Donald Trump,
especially criticism
directly of Donald Trump.
And I want to explain why.
First, of all,
I want to play some audio of Will Hurd,
who took on Trump directly at the dinner
last night. Take a listen.
Donald Trump
is running to stay out of prison.
And if we elect
I know, I know.
I know.
Listen, I know the truth.
The truth is hard
but if we elect Donald Trump,
we are willingly giving Joe Biden
four more years in the White House.
And inside the room,
it was
incredibly loud forks
for banging on plates.
People were booing,
heard was essentially booed
off the stage.
So therein lies the conundrum, Fred,
because you want to have at least
if you're Mike Pence,
you want to peel off those voters,
you want the support of the Trump base,
but you somehow have to woo them
and yet criticize
his former running mate.
It's a very difficult line to thread.
All right.
And we're going to see how he tackles
the environment
where you are at the fire station today
when he arrives.
Kyung Lah thank you so much.